this is Jaco podcast number 377 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko good evening
good evening so
a while ago
we might even say
back in the day
in the dreams I gave some advice
a little advice to the boys in a certain
situation and
I think this piece of advice that I gave
it's one of those pieces advice very
simple piece of advice
very simple piece of advice
and yet if you follow this very simple
piece of advice
your whole life will be in a much better
place
gold nugget now I know that's a little
arrogant right to sit here and be say
tell you that I spewed some gold nugget
piece of advice right
but I think you might agree with me
when you hear this piece of advice I
gave some people and I've given it to
other people
over the years here's the here's the
very powerful piece of advice that will
help you much in life the piece of
advice is
don't do dumb [__]
and I know it's not earthbreaking right
I know it's not some ancient
um Western or Eastern philosophical
statement
but let me ask you this
how many people
do you know
that have
either negatively significantly
negatively impacted their lives or
wrecked their lives
either slowly over time or very quickly
in some cases how many people do you
know that have really made a mess of
their lives by doing dumb [__]
I know a lot of them
and as I was like I said I was actually
giving this advice to someone the other
day and I started thinking to myself
this is so obvious
why would anyone
do dumb [__] why why would you why would
you do it literally what are the reasons
and then I started thinking about
actual reasons
that cause people to do dumb [__] myself
included and I'm sure we'll find some
examples for Echo Charles
but I thought let's sit down let me
think about some of these things
and we can discuss
some of the primary reasons for us to do
dumb [__] and that way maybe we can
prevent some people
and that means me and that means you
from doing some dumb [__] okay first on
my list
this one's real obvious this one this
one is the winner by far
alcohol
look yes
you take if you take the SEAL Teams yeah
or just take the military in general
if you removed alcohol from the equation
there would be a lot less dumb [__]
going on look we're still doing dumb
[__] but when I used to have guys get in
trouble
95 of the time there was alcohol and
five involved think about that 95 of the
time when a seal did some dumb [__]
maybe 90 90 of the time there was
alcohol involved they were doing some
dumb [__] think about high school
right what goes on in high school when
people get in trouble in high school
um
probably 80 percent
maybe 70. well you got that little you
got that little Spike of uh
rebelliousness that's going on in high
school that doesn't require alcohol yeah
it doesn't require the stupidity of
alcohol College when you see when you
see like when something hits the news
for college yeah yeah
there's alcohol involved that might be
97 right the Frat guy dies from too much
alcohol
the date rape thing happens because the
guy's drunk the girl's drunk like it's
just a disaster
the vandalism happens the kid falls out
the window drunk like you take all those
College things
97 alcohols in the game yeah am I right
yeah that sounds right to me too you're
more of the college experience than me
yep yep
the military like I said and life in
general
life in general
this alcohol thing is just going to lead
to bad scenarios it's going to lead to
you doing dumb [__] some of it is hey
you get pulled over by the cops you you
might be in that mindset like well I'm
fine but you blow a
you know
0.081 or whatever so now you're
technically you're you're drunk yeah
guess what you're out 10 grand you're
maybe out your driver's license you get
an accident with that now you're getting
sued like it's just a total life
turnaround in three seconds never mind
if you're actually drunk and you do
something dumb you hit somebody whatever
that's terrible you get in fights
but I mean you go to does are there any
fights
in the supermarket right there are
occasionally yeah not really though
right but not a lot yeah low percentage
are there any fights
on the the uh
the boardwalk like during the day on a
Saturday there can be but there's not a
lot but what about Saturday night what
changed it's darker yeah but what really
changed they put that they put that
boost they put that whiskey in the scene
everybody some people go crazy by the
way some people alcohol makes them go
crazy yeah this is a legitimate thing
yeah like I have friends
they're drinking they're not gonna
they're actually not gonna do anything
stupid they're gonna go They're gonna
have a drink it's no big deal yeah I
have some friends
when they drink alcohol
they're they're just gonna lose their
mind yeah they're gonna lose their mind
you have to watch you have to put a a
party of
of Warriors to like keep them under
control handlers yeah straight up
so
there you go
I uh my boss in one of the nightclubs I
worked at in Hawaii didn't drink or he
told me he didn't drink I said oh why
not you know because I kind of was it
didn't compute we work in the nightclub
or whatever he's one of the few people
and he said I'm a belligerent drunk oh
he knew it he was self-aware yep he
totally was but but what was more like
what made an impact on me was the idea
of being a belligerent drunk because he
just said I'm a belligerent junk so that
to me like how it came off to me it was
like
he knows and we all know about what a
belligerent drunk is like someone who
gets drunk and just wants to start stuff
on whatever scale hell you know like I
want to start I'm gonna start a fight
with my friends I told you about an
argument I tell you about my buddy like
he was passed out on a high boy table
you know what that is it's like a
standing Like A standing table but you
can have a tall stool yeah or whatever
so he's kind of just passed out on that
you know it's it's oh by the way it's
only like 10 o'clock at night
and he's passed out drunk we've been
drinking since whenever this is back in
the day like we're just stupid and and
so you know I I meet some girls they're
like hey let's go to this other bar and
I'm like yeah you know this is backing
them
and uh so I'm like okay we're gonna go
to this other bar so I wake him up
and I say hey bro hey we're going to
this other bar he like stands up looks
at me look he kind of looks normal
he takes two steps and he takes a swing
at some random dude that's walking away
or walking by him with his girlfriend he
takes a swing at this guy yeah I grab
him and I get a hold of him and he's
yelling he's going what did he do like
that's what my that's what my friend is
saying he's going what did he do what
did he do I'm like he didn't do anything
man he didn't do anything it's okay he's
like what did he do and I get him
outside and meanwhile the guy gets
outside
and as we get outside
the guy sees that I'm holding my buddy
back
and the guy looks at me goes yeah you
better hold on to him and I look at the
guy and go hey man if you don't get out
of here I'm gonna let him go and then
the dude just slicked us like when he
took off he didn't want none of that no
but that's that's
animalistic Behavior coming out yeah
this is no judgment no judgment like his
judgment is just and by the way this guy
who's a friend of mine he didn't have a
real
he was kind of a uh he's just gonna take
action type of bra yeah you know what
I'm saying apparently sober or not yeah
like when he's sober he might have
like maybe two or three seconds of
consideration before action and those
are not long seconds you know he's
considering Maybe
can I get killed right now or can I get
arrested is there a cop in the in the
immediate 20 feet around me no I can get
away with this I'm gonna do it but when
alcohol is involved there's no thought
process whatsoever just just zero I'm
just gonna do whatever pops into my head
yeah
that's alcohol
so that's why I think you know that we I
think everybody's got a kind of joke
like this of you know if it wasn't for
alcohol
the Irish would rule the world the seals
would rule the world you know like you
say that about all these different
cultures that the English would rule the
world like alcohol will screw you up and
make you do dumb [__] oh yeah you bro
you brought up the um judgment thing
there was the movie Kingpin remember
that one the bowling movie bowling movie
so he said he said something at some
point where the guy you know he's trying
to develop this new bowling Talent right
the Amish dude and then he said uh they
did something that failed it was massive
failure and he's like you said you could
develop me into the next Talent he was
like I've been hammered for the last you
know 15 years or whatever so my judgment
isn't all that good and it kind of got
me thinking where even if I'm at home by
myself in front of the computer watching
TV whatever like by myself
my judgment is not good drinking alcohol
so like and okay so I'm gonna admit this
to you so all these the dumb [__] I do
which thankfully doesn't have huge
repercussions but I'll get like an idea
to do some cool [__]
brother there's like a handful of people
that'll literally like vouch for this
this fact I'll get an idea and I'll be
like oh that would be so cool if I like
started doing this right and I was like
who can I do that like who would who
would help me with this like who would
bring some really cool [__] to the table
for this idea that I'm about to develop
that I just developed right now
so I'll text like Keen Cornelius
like whatever that is dumb it's a dumb
idea but the fact is my point is like
judgment is just bad yeah even it can
literally seem like bro this is gonna
change like the whole trajectory of like
what we're doing you know
and then you wake up up the next day you
see the text because it's like three in
the morning so the normal person's not
gonna text back at that time so in the
morning I get the reply text and oh I'm
waiting I'm waiting to hear this idea
you know all this stuff and I'm like ah
yeah never mind about that idea but it
happens a lot even if the kind like and
I'm the kind where I all know like if I
was drinking or whatever I'll know like
hey like sometimes I do come up with bad
ideas so I understand so but so I'm
gonna be aware of that you know even
though I know still still judgment
terrible we have a thing in the SEAL
Teams where guys would be sitting around
drinking and they'd say like oh we were
solving the world's problems yeah right
is that a common thing yeah okay yeah
it's very similar to what you're talking
about where you're thinking oh you know
if we just did this and we didn't you're
coming up with the dumbest Solutions
and thank God you don't act on them or
whatever they might be hopefully
hopefully but
case in point yeah alcohol big
contributor to doing dumb [__] the the
you said something about the or when you
mentioned the drunk drinking and driving
right where that one so
okay there's the kind where you drink a
like some you drink some and you're like
maybe I'm over maybe I'm not but like I
for real feel I can I can drive there's
no problem like the risk like it doesn't
even seem like a risk a that's the
alcohol doing telling you that that's a
b it is a risk straight up risk and it's
not a hard decision technically it's
like not a small risk either yeah huge
and so but it's not like a hard decision
it's not like oh my gosh let me just
weigh out these pros and cons and like
man okay you know call kids all guns all
of them it's so easy like so easy to
tell meanwhile we do it especially now
with Uber yeah I mean for real like uber
is just a problem solver yeah fully so
let's
make sure I guess you know when people
do the um like the psychological or the
psycho drugs like yes psychedelics or
whatever they say oh you need to go to
like a special place special place to do
where you want where you're a coach you
don't do them at like Costco
you're supposed to go to a place where
you're not gonna hurt anybody you're not
gonna hurt yourself it's you kind of
need to set yourself up with alcohol
like that
I think that that's actually a good idea
yeah put yourself in this like if you
really feel the need yeah
go to a situation
where you're not going to be around
these these problems that are going to
come
that sounds funny but really when you
kind of think of it and ignore some of
the social stuff
that's probably a good idea e and B when
you really think look at it kind of from
that perspective
a bar and Nightclub is the literal exact
opposite so you said let's have you in a
responsible safe area with a coach that
can guide you through it you know maybe
multiple coaches you know because this
is a powerful drug and it's going to
make you have feelings that you think
are real but they're not and all this
stuff and that's true but actually you
know what instead of that let's do this
let's put you in a place where you can
get as much as you want literally as
much as long as you don't pass out or
start throwing up or whatever you can
have as much as you want as long as you
can afford it by the way so we're gonna
charge you a little bit extra on that
one
as much as you want and we're gonna put
you in the vicinity of two things that
are probably the most emotionally
compelling things that a human being can
do with if you're a boy it's girls who
are dressed up the best they can by the
way and to look as
let's say attractive as possible
and a bunch of other guys who are out to
do the same thing while you know to uh
compete with socially
that you don't know and have no like you
know ties to it whatever oh yeah that's
the perfect recipe for safety I was I
was talking to a friend of mine just a
couple years ago and he had I hadn't
seen him in a long time
and I was like oh what have you been up
to and he kind of told me what he's been
up to and he said yeah you know I
whatever I got you know I got in trouble
here I got arrested there I and he said
you know I was addicted to I started
using crack or I started using Coke then
I started using crack then I started
using matte like the whole nine yards
and and as I'm talking to it he goes you
know what the craziest thing is
he said the craziest thing is
the worst drug for me when he that's
what he got arrested for he goes what
the only thing I've been arrested for
he'd been to rehab and stuff for these
other drugs he said the only thing I've
actually been arrested for
is when I drink alcohol he goes when I
drink alcohol I'm totally insane and I
can vouch for this I've seen him drink
alcohol and he is totally insane
and he said is this craziest thing that
the drug that makes me totally insane is
the only one that I can walk down to the
corner store and buy as much of it as I
possibly want he said it's it's terrible
that's crazy and that's a very good
point and the weird thing about it is is
that alcohol affects different people
differently I mean for real it does yeah
and so some people that's why when I
talk to like younger people
you don't know how it's going to affect
you yeah and if you don't know well
again what's the risk that you're taking
the risk that you're taking is maybe
this is just you're one of those people
that just goes freaking ape [__] when
you drink when you drink this stuff and
you get addicted to it the whole nine
yards yeah
even and speaking of just setting
yourself up at a minimum
like oh you're gonna go well you know
I'm gonna go I'm gonna drive down to the
bar and I might have a few drinks just
don't drive there just get an Uber there
yeah you know like put yourself if
you're smart at least set yourself up
for some kind of not being an idiot yeah
that's some legit mitigation right there
for sure the the scary one just one more
ad additional scary part of the alcohol
and this is this this is it lands on
people on different areas of the
spectrum here but what it does so you
know you can think and we all think
sometimes most of the time anyway oh I
can drink and like I'll just I'll just
really monitor myself and focus on
monitoring myself I won't do nothing
dumb right I promise to your wife or
whoever but what alcohol does is it
literally makes bad
ideas seem good like good ideas they
flip over so much perfect personal
experience with that bro
that's a reflection yes we got asked on
the Underground somebody asked about
alcohol and like well you know I feel
like I should cut it down and I've been
addicted like he had a big thing he said
you know how how can I do a better job
of cutting it down and you know I
basically said at the end I kind of went
around I said listen man I just can't
get behind it at all I just can't I just
can't tell you that there's any positive
way that you should be doing this just
you shouldn't be doing it that I had
several people reach out to me and say
thanks for saying that because that's
the right answer the right answer is
you shouldn't be doing this and you just
especially if you have any kind of you
have a problem with it you shouldn't do
it at all period end of story and look
if you're one of those people that's
lucky enough that you can have a few and
it's okay and you like a glass of wine
with dinner and all that stuff I get it
and I'm not trying to uh say anything
bad about you and I'm not trying to take
away your bottle of wine or your beer
after a hard day work
if you can do that cool good for you but
if you're one of those people that that
glass of wine turns into a bottle of
wine or that that two beers turns into
eight twelve you know 24 beers that's
not good and you shouldn't be doing it
and if you're one of those people that
your judgment goes completely off the
rails you shouldn't be doing it there's
just other things you should do so
had to put that one
as the number one
I would say for people between the ages
of you know 16 and
35. yeah
probably the number one cause of doing
dumb [__] alcohol so just be careful out
there people drugs I had to list drugs
too because obviously drugs are similar
I you know everything that we just said
about alcohol you can kind of say about
drugs too
um
yeah so the alcohol or sorry drugs I I
think I've told you this before I had a
friend that uh
he
he told he was
he did math and uh
he said he just gotten out of jail he
did like seven years in jail for
stealing and doing all kinds of stuff
and he was doing all this bad stuff
because he was addicted to meth and he
said that
the first time he ever tried meth the
very first time he ever tried meth he
said it was the only thing that he ever
wanted to do for the rest of his life he
was like 100 totally addicted and he
started in his immediate family stealing
everything that they had then his
grandma then his granddad then his aunt
and uncle he stole everything from his
family then everything from his friends
and then he went to a different city and
did the same thing again and same thing
again same thing again until he finally
ended up a place where his luck ran out
he got caught and it ended up doing
seven years in prison
from one
try of meth yeah so
drugs again it's like the same thing I
just can't I just can't
you know you know how some people say
they have an addictive personality and
it's almost like a little bit of a
humble brag I got an addictive
personality the reason I said I think I
used to say that for real oh yeah I kind
of have an addictive personality and I
actually think I do not actually have an
addictive personality uh you know I I
like to do some things like I really
like doing Jiu Jitsu yeah
you know could I say oh yeah I'm kind of
addicted to juice
but it's not it's not like running my
life right what does that mean what do
you how do you interpret that when
someone's like I haven't addicted to
meaning what do you think that means
meaning meaning oh you try alcohol it
makes you feel good yeah you're now
gonna get as much as you can and you're
not gonna stop until something goes bad
let's say not even drug or alcohol like
just a per if you have an addictive
personality you know yeah I don't really
I don't know if he's even a technical
term for it I think I feel like I used
to say it
you know when I was younger like I kind
of had almost like a humble brag yeah
and probably when I was like 30 I was
like actually I don't think I have an
addictive personality at all yeah like
we would go on ships where you're not
allowed to drink and I just wouldn't
care at all right you know wouldn't care
at all I'm just like whatever addictive
personality to me strikes me as
something where like if you like kind of
get into something you know there's some
big thing small thing whatever whatever
you get into you just go hard
into in into that subject or activity
that's what it feels like it means you
know and Tech I mean in a way
kind of know some people like that where
it's like oh he's on this now and he
just spends like years just being into
this every day kind of a thing since I
can see it but I think you're right and
I didn't really think about that where
it's like it's kind of a humble brag
yeah as if to say I just go hard if I
get into something I just go hard that's
how I am you know it's almost like
saying I'm kind of a perfectionist that
that whole thing you know it's sort of
like I've got an addictive personality
you just gotta hey man I'm just gonna go
so I don't think I have that but I
definitely know people that
definitely I know some people that went
hard in these directions in various
directions
and you can also you know you hear about
people that were drug addicts and when
they get done with drug addicts they get
off of them and then they become like
Addicted to Fitness yeah you know what I
mean they just oh you school I was a I
was a alcoholic and I started working
out and they just get addicted to that
right I started running marathons I
started what right so though that's what
I think the when I think of addictive
personality it's someone that's just
disregarding other parts of their life
yeah yeah and they're just doing this
thing yeah whatever that thing is
uh so there's alcohol drugs okay now the
next one here
that I was thinking about is and a lot
of these things are related but these
kind of instinctual or animalistic
drives that we have as human beings
so these can make you do dumb things
right so the you know you got food
right you got the reproductive Drive sex
you've got the aggression aggression
like you have a natural different levels
but a natural level of aggression when I
have you ever done a sport where
something made you mad like this you got
frustrated with the support and you like
hit
like you get frustrated on the mats you
like hit the mats or you've seen someone
like punch the punch the wall mat after
they get tapped right yeah yeah fully
that's the thing or they get
uh they get submitted or they get worked
over on the mat and they start to get
hostile yeah oh wait are you talking
about just hostile in general or hostile
towards the person or whatever both okay
General hostility like there's an
aggression level that yeah yeah gotcha
and so those are animalistic things
animalistic drives that we have that can
make you do dumb things and here's a to
not go too crazy on an example but you
have an animalistic drive to eat food so
that can make you make bad decisions
because if you get a freaking big ass uh
box of donuts in front of you you have
an instinct to eat those donuts
100 yeah and that's you know same thing
with you know with uh the sex drive that
you have you know you could be in a
situation like oh the animalistic part
of you could just make you break down
and you're gonna go
the aggression thing you get into a
scenario where you get back into a
corner the animalistic things like oh I
better protect myself I need to get
aggressive right now
fear also can make you do things which
is an animalistic
emotion I guess is fear
uh
and there's some animalistic things that
are positive too um you know being
protective yeah you know like when when
a guy runs into a house or or a mom runs
into a burning house to save their kid
yeah they're like being animalistically
protective yeah you know you hear about
the bear protecting its Cubs well humans
will do that too it's a positive thing
but you have to pay attention
to make sure that your animal instincts
aren't making you do dumb [__] yeah
because they can
think so that you talked about the food
thing so
and I say this because this is probably
very like prevalent and common where you
know how you talk about fasting yeah
stuff like that so some people they
might not be ready for that hunger and
we've talked about that too where if
you're not ready for that hunger or
actually forget fasting
what if he just didn't eat today because
you didn't have time or whatever right
you just not you just a normal person
and then you then you get home okay
let's just say it it's me all right so I
get home and I'm hungry from because I
missed lunch because I was doing
whatever
and I get home and
you know I'm like many people where I
pay attention to what I eat I'm not just
like oh I'm hungry oh there's a
McDonald's that sounds good but you know
like so I pay attention and try to you
know I'd be I'm thoughtful deliberate
yeah deliberate yes exactly so if I'm
hungry though super hungry
say eight hours no food like that's
hunger you know
um in my opinion but I'll go home and
then if I see some like candy walnuts
cruising over there or some chips like
over there or whatever like I'll get
into them you know when I when I didn't
have any plan to do that that was a part
of any program it wasn't part of being
my plan yeah you know but I will be way
more thoughtless of what I eat when
you're hungry you know where it's like
oh no no dinner's coming out right now
oh you're still pulling me through you
know the so that can kind of like make
you go into that Spire that animalistic
like Spiral you know so you that that's
why this is on the list man oh you got
it you gotta watch out and really this
is and this it kind of goes for this
whole list I'll call it like everything
even stuff that'll seem real obvious to
some people
part of the problem or if not a
significant part of the problem is that
you're not paying attention it's almost
like you're not like you lost Focus for
one second and you just let the
animalistic whatever kind of take over
yeah you know the like the momentum of
the what you know your whole thing
whatever you're doing even the alcohol
thing you know you saying I know you're
gonna talk about this or peer pressure
right where peer pressure doesn't come
in in ways like how you see on the old
school 80s 90s commercials where it's
like come on don't be a chicken it
doesn't always come like that you know
it comes in like a lot of subtle ways
that just sort of you're going forward
in life and the peer pressures nudges
you right to the side like why would
anyone see and and this is no I'm not
like judging or nothing anyone who does
this but why would anyone ever smoke a
cigarette like there's no reason ever
especially now ever to smoke cigarettes
but why do people smoke cigarettes there
should be not one single human being
technically or in America technically
who should start smoking yeah should be
zero like that decision-making process
is polluted by this peer pressure by by
something it's polluted by something
distracting their decision-making
process
which so and that's why I don't judge
because let's face it you know uh I I've
said this about alcohol too
back in the day you know if you wanted
to prove that you were kind of willing
to sacrifice for the team and that you
were tough one of the ways you could do
that is like oh watch How Much I Can
Drink watch how much can abuse my own
body and then still go on right you see
somebody in this day and age if you were
if you're going to make a decision to
make to smoke cigarettes it's literally
a way of saying hey look I don't care
about anything I don't care about my own
health that's how much I don't care it's
a it's a statement I think if you were
gonna be that that would be the only
reason why I think someone would go oh
yeah look at me I don't even care this
is horrible for me I can get a horrible
disease and I'm just over here smoking a
cigarette yeah postie right post Malone
just out there singing and and freaking
smoking a cigarette yeah it's a bummer
he must be addicted to the cigarettes
though huh yeah and and to me this is
all real this is this is this is real
life this is this isn't like oh you guys
are so dumb it's like no no it's
actually pretty obvious like I see
exactly why that's going on because I'm
and peer pressure into doing so much
dumb stuff where as an adult they'll be
like hey did you do this and then to say
yes is actually embarrassing even though
it's something that like plenty of young
people do or whatever there's a lot of
stuff that go like that and go like that
you know that we've all done or whatever
so hey that's just one of them so
whatever dude you dig
but when you really stop and think which
I was gonna say this earlier where a lot
of this
it's crazy how it goes back to all these
simple simple terms you know back when
you're like five years old when your
teacher telling you hey don't do dumb
stuff okay cool I won't hey stop and
think we all hear that just stop and
think right so look if you just stop and
think before you're about to smoke your
first cigarette stop and think and then
make a conscious decision you'll be like
oh wait I am probably not gonna smoke
that cigarette yeah
which goes back to this very simple
piece of advice that's why this simple
piece of advice is powerful yes
uh so there you go and and you know what
you're gonna see like a lot of these
things are tied together for instance
when you drink alcohol your animalistic
nature is more apps closer to the
surface yeah that's why we're fighting
more you know like that's why that's why
you get done with a night of drinking
and you swing by that Pizzeria you know
you're like give me that triple Chi
right give me the triple cheese you know
stack it up man what I was in Guam my
first deployment we would like drink and
then there was this
freaking uh like 24-hour gas station
Food Mart yeah and they had these
microwavable rib sandwiches and I would
literally get five of them and just sit
there and eat them at four o'clock in
the morning boneless there's yeah just a
boneless but it's like a McRib sandwich
that you threw in the microwave I mean
there's probably nothing worse you could
eat as a human I know you know but five
or four o'clock in the morning three
o'clock in the morning
kid hungry yeah let's eat this crap yep
so
there you go uh watch out for that this
next one this one you know this next
one's really obviously very very very
clear very prominent um that's our ego
could be
as far as internally as far as who we
are you take away the external drugs and
alcohol ego
is gonna be a huge problem it's we do so
many dumb things because of our ego and
what's interesting is he starts seeing
the thread between
the ego and sort of your animalistic
drives there's a connection right
there's a connection between aggression
you know when when you get in my face
we're in a bar or or in the supermarket
doesn't really matter you you get in my
face you steal my cart right oh yeah and
I get mad and but and I might get mad or
I might be like hey what are you doing
but then you say what are you gonna do
about it you just you just attack my ego
you know now I might do some dumb [__]
yeah because let's face it what am I
gonna get out of fighting you in the in
the Vons parking lot
what am I gonna get out of that I'm not
gonna get anything out of it in fact
there's
almost no good outcome at a minimum
I skinned my I broke a finger or skinned
my knee or I mean at a maximum I get
killed right you said you you shank me
with a freaking uh uh a butter knife a
sharpened butter knife or you shoot me
because you got concealed carry like so
what's happening that's an ego situation
so how many times are we doing dumb [__]
because our ego is getting in the way
and driving our decision making process
because we talk about all the time from
a leadership perspective of course oh
echo's got a plan and I've got my plan I
think my plan's better and my ego gets
in the way that's cool we get that but
as far as just on an individual human
being level how much dumb stuff are you
doing because your ego gets in the way
and and the the answer is a ton that's
the answer
everything from an animalistic fight
because your ego gets in the way to you
know you're talking to your wife
and she says something that offends your
ego so what do you do you snap back or
cut what do you say Snapback or clap
back I I think you might be both okay
you get aggressive back at her yeah and
all of a sudden you're escalating the
situation now instead of going out for
dinner and having a nice Friday night
everything's a disaster
you're doing dumb stuff because your ego
what about your
you know you're out with your buddies
you're 16 years old and it's time to do
something crazy
oh we're gonna jump off this thing we're
gonna dive over that thing we're gonna
throw things at this vehicle like we're
gonna get do Troublesome stuff and you
know it's not smarter than someone's
like oh what are you a wimp
your ego gets offended now what are you
gonna do oh watch this
I'm gonna prove it
so we do dumb [__] because of our ego
put it in check it's not just a
leadership thing it's a life thing
it's a life thing even this even that
peer pressure peer pressure they use ego
as part of peer pressure
oh what do you think you're too good no
I'll do this too boom next thing out
there give me pass me the cigarette
stupid
um
anything else on ego yeah that you said
um you mentioned the thing with your
wife where it's like instead of a nice
night out at dinner things are a
disaster yeah so it's like you're
literally talking from a detached
perspective because currently you're not
in an argument with your wife no or
going out to dinner by the way so but
that's such a like it makes it so clear
when you point it out right so if you
can even tell that that to yourself in
in in your mind like oh what do you want
to do what do you want to do you want to
go out to dinner and have a good time or
you want to be in an argument with your
wife for an indefinite amount of time
because your ego is a weird thing worse
than out there could be worse than
alcohol by the way but that's a side
note um so you ever watched you watch
Training Day right yeah oh yeah so he
would say this he would say he would do
that what you just did he'd be like hey
you want to go to jail you want to go
home
and it puts you into that perspective
where it's like
let me think because we you know we all
even if we've never been to jail we can
kind of imagine what it's like to be in
jail and you're usually there for a kind
of long regardless if you're getting
sentenced or not you're getting held in
jail you're not there for a second you
know you're there it's it's a shitty day
right
or you want to go home and we all know
what it feels like to be home you put
those two thoughts in your mind like oh
what's the scenario where he sets this
up uh well the first one is is he
talking to a perpetrators yeah the first
one was and then um
and then he said uh I forget the second
one he said it and then Jake the other
guy said it to him too at the end or
whatever but it was like a kind of a
recurring thing but yeah exactly it was
like yeah you want to go to jail and you
want to go home oh he said it to Snoop
Dogg that was the second one if I'm not
mistaken but yeah I felt it
uh Jack so there you go watch out for
your ego
let's face it your ego I'm get I'm once
you internal forces ego is number one I
think you're right and I think it's
actually just as bad as alcohol if not
worse because like I think it might be
worse because it's internal but when you
think about it think about the effects
the potential effects some people I get
it where they can drink alcohol or have
an ego they can kind of they'll do it'll
do some damage sure better to not have
it sure technically but no no huge harm
no huge foul with alcohol and ego but
ego can literally ruin a relationship
many relationships with critical people
like your family or whatever just ego
yeah well you know what's what's messed
up about ego is you know you wake up
from the dumb decision that you made
when you were drunk and at least you get
to say hey I'm sorry
and look we're not you have to take
ownership of the fact that you were dumb
enough to get drunk but if your buddy
does something when they're drunk and
you wake up in the morning you're like
dude they're like bro and you're kind of
like you get it right but if they're
just doing it consciously without any
impairment and it's because they're ego
it's like they have no control over that
just means that they're just bad it's
exactly right it's part of your
personality bro so it's like like Jocko
was drunk he told me like that he never
really liked me or I don't know
something that was like it could have
hurt us
and then he can come back the next day
and you'll feel the guilty and be like
hey I was drunk and like freaking my
judge like I don't even know why you
could apologize really bring up the
alcohol thing and I can be like I'll see
I could see it that makes sense to me
yeah I've known I've had plenty of
friends that did dumb stuff oh yeah when
they were drunk and I was like bro yeah
yeah and but forgiveness is very easy
yeah and you might be weary next time
they start drinking you're like okay you
know you can be dumb again but when it's
your ego it's like bro that's not some
external alcohol that's part of who you
are bro so you gotta watch out what
about what to eat what about with
alcohol unleashes the ego too oh damn
the double win you know that's freaking
ridiculous that's right and that then
you go even though they're they're like
I'm drunk you're like yeah but that was
well there's some Thrills here yeah the
truth serum's coming out yeah then even
that though it's like again there's
levels to it which you know obviously
but
that is the real thing when the ego
comes out actually that's pretty common
right there like [__] I'm so late
because it can be some B9 egotistical
stuff you can say like stuff that's like
if you could see yourself you'd be
embarrassed but hey man you're not
hurting my feelings so carry on brother
wait say that again what's this for so
if you're drunk and your ego comes out
uh-huh you know start bragging about
yourself all the cool stuff that you did
and how awesome you are or whatever come
on bro that's real some people do that
kind of stuff but that doesn't
necessarily hurt anyone's feelings or
nothing you know you didn't like do any
kind of betrayal type stuff or like flip
out on your girlfriend or hit her or
nothing like that like it's benign you
know it doesn't like you're gonna be
like yeah you sounded dumb but you're
sober now so whatever like you didn't
ruin our relationship you know
but it's still real nonetheless
all right watch out for your ego uh next
category it's actually a pretty big
category the category is called emotions
and look we we start looking at dumb
[__] that we did like how many freaking
males between the ages of 16 and 25 have
broken their hand punching a wall with
their back
have broken their car window have broken
their mirror have put a hole in the
drywall
how many guys have done that like it's a
big number yeah it's a big big number
so anger it's real obvious your emotion
gets out of jail getting jealous people
do I mean let's face it people murder
people when they're jealous they kill
other people and go to and kill
themselves and like it's just
uh terrible yeah the anxiety
you know you people are making bad
decisions because they're they're
totally nervous about what's happening
and it prevents them from moving forward
guilt now you know there's some of these
things look a certain level of guilt
and shame like those type of things
there's certain certain reasons why
those things keep you in line a little
bit yeah exactly like oh like echo's got
echo's supposed to be moving today but
and I was gonna help him but you know
what uh I'd rather uh you know what I
feel guilty I go help him move yeah yeah
you know yeah there's a certain level of
this stuff that's okay but it can also
if it's taken too far can be bad Envy
same thing
uh just getting in that point of
sadness or depression where you don't
feel like anything's worth anything and
now you do something stupid so emotions
can can make you do some dumb things
and and what's tricky about emotions
is
no one well I don't know say no one it's
very difficult
for someone to be able to externally
show you that the emotions that you're
feeling are not worth
decisions that you're making you know I
mean um
telling someone that just got dumped by
their girlfriend just got dumped by
their boyfriend that like Hey listen
you're gonna be okay you won't even
remember that person you know you're in
you're in 10th Grade
by the time you're 23 you will not
remember this person's name but you
can't tell them that you can't they're
just emotionally wrapped up they got the
the
the anger the sadness it's all in there
and they might do dumb stuff
so
teaching people
as early as you can to be able to
control their emotions
and I don't even want to say control
your emotions but but imagine being able
to harness and not be at the whim of
your emotions like surfing right like
you don't just learn you don't learn to
stop waves from coming you learn to ride
the waves and not let them smash you
into the Rocks that's what you learn to
do so learning like oh there's some big
emotions coming through me right now I
don't wanna
let those things push me into the rocks
or let them hold me underwater I want to
be able to ride them and use them
and not get abused by them
pretty simple straightforward concept
yeah
but very difficult especially you know
uh
let's face it when you're when you're a
toddler they have no emotional control
yeah you know someone takes their rattle
they start screaming right they start
crying rattle right the little rattle
yep right it's hard and then as you get
older you you should
get more and more control over your
emotions
that's what's supposed to happen you
might not let you might
still have things happen where you don't
get control of your emotions so the more
you can explain that to people the more
you can explain like hey this is not a
good idea
hey this is your emotions right now
which is real look if you were freaking
mad about something I was like Hey Yoko
you're just getting emotional you're not
gonna be happy it's gonna make you more
emotional actually
that's why I have in leadership strategy
and tactics you know the whole idea of
reflect and diminish like you gotta show
you that I understand your emotions like
that kind of thing yeah
but don't let your emotions drive your
decision-making process
that's it
that one since it's a part of your
natural self emotions it kind of seems
like in I'm not a psychologist you know
this about me
it's but it does seem like but it does
seem like this since it's part of your
natural self
you kind of got to train that dude 100
like alcohol you don't have to train you
just don't drink alcohol simply make the
decision but emotions like you gotta
kind of train that like you mentioned
the surfing yeah like try to throw
someone in me you know you know me have
a snowboarding background so you know
kind of the same deal throw them on a
wave bro they're gonna be flipping out
they're gonna be fighting the wave all
day you know so even going you know like
uh I'm teaching my son to go under the
wave right when they get big it doesn't
matter how big the wave is you go under
no no Factor you know
but people don't be like hey the way
it's gonna smash me why would I go down
there and get smashed it's like that's
the intuitive thing or whatever but the
more you do it the more you're like oh
here comes a big wave oh the the my
automatic thing is to go underneath
right after you train or if you have
that experience for a while but emotions
and so emotion is kind of that same
thing where especially if you can
detached word I learned if you can
detach and really identify oh I'm
feeling this emotion right now then bro
it it creates that perfect filter of
emotions and behavior you can still feel
it yeah bro should I get a little only
like oh trigger not enough sleep and
deal with like a five-year-old who's
determined doing something bro that'll
be the test but and I've done that say
that because I've done that before and
I I found myself oh I'm feeling super
frustrated with this kid right now super
frustrated but I'm identifying I can
like see it almost like from a detached
and I'm like I won't flip out on them
because like I'm not going to make the
decision right now to flip out them it's
like perfect it's that perfect filter
you know
but yeah you got to train that though
because let's face it if you like if
you're one of these people who flips out
all the time and you don't like mentally
address it you're just gonna flip out
all the time that's just how yeah and
there's adults that flip out yes sir
there is freaking terrible and what's
really terrible is you know if I get
angry
if you and I work together and when
something's not going my way I get angry
and you just kind of like back down
because you don't want to you don't want
the drama yeah
I guess what I just learned that works
my anger is good my temper is good and
or if you're you know if I got if I got
my wife and I see that every time I get
sad she kind of like doesn't want me to
be sad so she kind of capitulates to my
ideas and all of a sudden I'm getting
reinforced that my little emotions will
help me win bro that's a good that's
such a or your wife can do that to you
you know like oh you know instead of
just being like okay these are just
emotions I'm not gonna We're Not Gonna
We're Not Gonna deal in emotions yeah
look and this once again this doesn't
mean you can ignore emotions if your
wife's sad about something you can be
like hey quick and emotional
right it doesn't work but no put them in
the calculus but don't let them be the
the main force behind your decisions not
gonna go good I mean it's as simple as
like when you go to the when you go to
the grocery store when you're really
hungry yes dude you're making all kinds
of emotional decisions you'll come out
of there you got freaking all kinds of
food I just went up on on a trip and we
were going we were going to be on the
house we're gonna be in this house for
like four days yeah and we left early in
the morning and then we drove and blah
blah and by the time we stopped at the
grocery store I was catabolic you know
what I mean
I was in there buying all we had enough
food for a month not real but we
probably had enough food for two weeks
yeah and we were in this we were in the
house for five days yeah at the end I
was like dude I'm an idiot a matter of
fact as soon as I ate yeah we got to the
house I ate and I was like dude how am I
gonna eat all this we got I haven't
eaten
haven't eaten that that mozzarella with
the freaking uh pepperoni no mozzarella
no mozzarella
fresh mozzarella with basil oh yeah the
tomato and the oil and I don't like the
Tomato but I put the oil in the balsamic
vinaigrette on it and
um
I got like
so much of that I had enough for weeks
oh yeah and I didn't I think I had one
serving of it
so that's emotional decision
it's funny because I everyone knows that
but until right now it's it's
emotionalism it's also the uh the
animalistic Drive you're like oh food I
need as much as I can I need to hoard as
much as I can making bad decisions you
know did you get chips
no I feel like chips always sneak in
there when you're hungry are you not
into chips no no no I'm I'm definitely
I'll I'll eat chips I mean
chips taste delicious let me say that
right so true when you're like right
when you eat something you immediately
figure out all the dumb stuff you just
buy it's so true God it's so true yeah
we got to the house unpacked and you
know what the thing is if I would have
had a Mulk just before I walked in there
I'd been good to go bro it helps it
would be good to go didn't do it brother
uh Girl Scout cookies those peanut
butter ones oh yeah I eat the whole box
no problem
there's no Factor no Factor
I have a Mulk intervene uh so there you
go that's kind of a combination
animalistic emotions the whole nine
yards next one peer pressure we kind of
brought this up already you'll do some
dumb [__] because of peer pressure
hey like you said sure there's a peer
pressure that's like come on what are
you a wimp there's that there's also the
subliminal peer pressure yeah
where everyone's doing what what's
happening and they're kind of giving you
just a look they're not even saying
anything they're just looking at you
that peer pressure can make you do some
dumb [__] yeah
lack of confidence yeah is makes you
more susceptible
to peer pressure the other thing that
you got to remember with peer pressure
is
you think everyone's looking at you yeah
they're actually not right it's actually
not that big of a deal right you think
like oh Everyone's Watching Me
everyone's gonna wonder if I'm gonna
smoke this or I'm gonna do this I
actually no one really cares and the
other thing is
there's a level of respect when you hold
a line and you have the confidence to be
like no no I'm not doing that tonight
I'm not doing that stupid maybe you
don't have to say I'm stupid because now
you're getting an argument or you're
causing problems but just be like no no
I don't you know no I don't drink yeah
no I'm not drinking tonight yeah
they like the crabs in the bucket though
they like to drag you in there they like
to put that drink in your hand do you
remember the first time he's tried
drinking
uh yeah I guess so
yeah but not really specifically yeah
I'd have to think through that
I'd have to think through that the first
time I try to drink as like I think as a
kid I'd like try a like a sip of beer
what does that taste like but I remember
the first time I like took a drink you
know like
it was like straight up peer pressure I
didn't start drinking but it was
straight up like there was like two guys
they snuck in which is weird because our
school was pretty like good it was a
team school but they snuck in a thing of
Crown Royal I remember because it had
that bag on it then they were like oh
come look come come come and one guy
wasn't one year younger than me uh two
guys were one year older than me and
they were like they're like oh yeah here
and they're Jay and I was just sort of
there because they were my friends but I
didn't drink I didn't want to drink
nothing like it would it didn't affect
me at all and they were like um here you
want some and I was like no no thanks
and I knew everyone knew that I wasn't
into drinking or whatever
and they go oh yeah that's okay and then
I looked over I remember this guy's name
is Owen
he had he looked at me I don't think he
even meant to he looked at me kind of
like oh like thanks like that's okay
it's okay like almost like he felt sorry
for me you know like you look stupid
right now but it's okay it's okay you
know kind of like almost like he felt
sorry for me but it was full on like
almost like
unintended peer pressure so he like gave
me this and I kind of looked up to him
because he could bench a lot and stuff
like that and then so I was like oh give
me it all try it or whatever and I like
tried it he's like oh it's warmer and he
was happy after that you know so I was
like that was full-on that's what that
100 that's what that was yeah I I didn't
start drinking until I got in the teams
and
for me it wasn't like a I kind of made a
conscious decision like oh that's kind
of what we're doing okay I was okay
that's that's what's happening yeah
that's that's what we do cool so
technically that's peer pressure too
yeah yeah yeah yeah but it wasn't like
uh it wasn't this overt thing like come
on Jocko you need to no no one said that
to me I was like okay looks like we're
drinking I never really done this before
so let's rock and roll yeah and then I
was like okay oh we're going hard cool
pass me another one that kind of thing
that's my my son was a little kid I'm
talking like maybe five or six yeah
probably five like little
and you know I had a couple of the boys
over whatever having some beers
and my son was like you know he kind of
like like he wanted to try some and I
was like cool I'll teach him not to
drink right now because you know beer
doesn't taste good to a little kid so I
hand him a freaking Rolling Rock
and he like takes a sip and then just
like within two seconds just like just
start trying to chug the whole thing
like he took a sip calculated and then
just boom like right back up and starts
trying to kind of grab it away from him
like dude what are you doing I did not
expect him to freaking go hard like that
yeah little kid yeah
that that he's an Australian dude and he
just like
he just drinks beer he gets he does this
technique where he like spins
yeah and he he's and he just chugs beer
that's his whole thing yeah there's a
few of those yeah that's crazy town
right there should be in the morning it
could be in the afternoon yeah it could
be in the evening he's just gonna slay a
beer
he cracks me up that's another form of
peer pressure right there for him for
what for us so actually that technically
it's not peer pressure right but it's
like influence it's like bad influence
you know it's like it's oh that's fun
it's fun it's light-hearted it's not
that big of a deal it's quirky it's you
know that's why it's not like
it's not like remember that the group it
was I think I'm pretty sure it was just
anti-smoking but they would call
themselves like truth it would say Truth
at the end it was like a bunch of
anti-smoking ads oh yeah yeah do these
crazy like real morbid stunts they'd lay
out a bunch of what look like dead
bodies and be like there's so many
people you're killing every year and
it's all these body bags they do that
kind of it's not like it was that it's
that this Australian guy is making it
fun yeah kind of like hey like that
that's the kind of uh behavior that
elicits like copycat Behavior you know
like oh maybe do it you know yeah it's
like no he looks like he's having a good
time good old time yeah it is kind of
cool like because I've seen some guys in
real life do that kind of stuff and it's
like oh damn it's pretty interesting and
he's got you know he's kind of got the
attitude that just makes it sound like
jelly time
that's real so uh that's peer pressure
though yeah but wait you're back to your
T the teams yeah that is peer pressure
because you know like you even said this
where peer pressure can be good if it's
for good stuff yeah you know so that's
like all your pressure in the team is
that good yeah they're like dude what
are you you're not you know oh I was
also like oh we're running like we're
working out like okay that's what we're
doing cool oh we're drinking cool I was
just on board for what we were doing
like bro whatever was happening I was on
board I wanted to be doing what we're
doing bruh 100 look right today we
trained today you know some good
training today was the um you know
so Vic text me or I talked to him on the
phone like three days ago yeah and he's
like hey we're gonna train on Friday too
I was oh yeah cool maybe put it on the
radar you know and then he's like oh
you're not gonna come or whatever all
this stuff no I said hey maybe you know
boom peer pressure that's number one
that's one step closer to the to the
persuasion he said I'm gonna text you
tomorrow as a reminder he does step two
because he told me text me now if I
don't show I I made a decision yeah I
didn't just forget about it like I do
all the time so what was the closer bro
we know
you and this is actually the most
influence I even told them this today
where you when you text you'll put like
if you're
sometimes you'll offer up some training
you know but if I'm into something I'll
be like having to catch you next time or
whatever but sometimes you'll put hey
we're gonna record after we Capital we
train you can't not go at that point
it's like hey you gotta Shuffle some
things around I plan to do squats yeah
why don't you do squats before right two
because they trained you're gonna do
squats after maybe maybe I'll do squats
tonight maybe I'm very very excessively
thankful that I worked out this morning
yeah and I don't have to go home and
work out yeah because that session that
we just did first of all I was not
having a good day you know what I mean
hard day you know what I'm saying
I didn't want to go you know I didn't
want to go yeah I
didn't want to go if there was a little
uh Bell to ring I would have been like
whoa what's that you know of course I'm
not ringing it
but I didn't want to go so I know I'm
already so that's already going in there
like you already are you know you're
gonna be hurting yeah and then you know
that mat right there you're not having
any easy rounds at all zero easy rounds
you're not even gonna have you're not
really even gonna have an easy 28
seconds yeah you're not gonna have any
easy minute and a half yeah even when
you're in between rounds you're like
breathing yeah you gotta you're focusing
on recovery yeah oh yeah so that peer
pressure it can be a good thing yeah it
can also make you do some dumb [__]
exactly right so peer pressure
technically is like that's not the the
cat the um the bad guy in the scenario
it's the dumb [__] that's the bad guy
Jack right along in there is groupthink
right this is peer pressure but it's
like it's like Amplified peer pressure
is group think this is wearing a mob
this is somebody starts breaking [__]
and you start breaking [__] too you
start doing dumb [__]
uh
making decisions based on what everybody
else is doing bad
then there's this whole genre of it of
just doing impulsive things and this is
sort of a result of a bunch of different
things that are happening right some
people are genetically impulsive by the
way yeah people have genetic
impulsiveness
sometimes it's based on what's going on
inside your brain as far as a brain
chemistry type scenario like dopamine
can make you impulsive to do to get a
little bit more dopamine right now even
though you know it's not smart
I mean look that's what's taking over
our minds right now with the people that
are on their social media on their
phones that's just dopamine they know
they're just impulsively swiping their
brain is not even thinking about what's
happening they're just looking to the
next freaking uh real yeah or whatever
so that impulsiveness is and you know
some people have
more self-control
look I I believe just like all of our
traits
there's a certain amount of self-control
that you have you can improve it
or you can let it get worse
but
I recommend you try and improve it I
recommend you pause for seven seconds
before before you do something impulsive
you know what's funny is when people
impulsively buy if you ever said someone
saying is an impulsive buy of course
impulse buy yeah that's the whole thing
that's a thing bro yeah well you know
the supermarket is set up where that's
part of the part of the funnel it's a
funnel straight up the counter there's a
freaking chocolate bar impulse buy all
day they put little things that are
gonna give you immediate gratification
like you're gonna get something that's
good you're gonna get to eat in in nine
more seconds yeah throw it in the
register throw it in the self checkout
so that isn't that crazy that you can
make dumb decisions you can do dumb [__]
because you're just being impulsive yeah
what's the biggest impulse buy you've
ever made biggest top man I don't know
vehicle
no no
house thankfully I'm very
um what's the opposite of impulsive
with the exception of the freaking uh
Reese's Sticks you ate that before right
they're kind of like you know what
kitkats are you know right so it's like
a KitKat but a big big beefy version of
KitKat with peanut butter two so this
chocolate and peanut butter I don't know
if that would that KitKat especially
young think about it the thing about
kitkats I used to have them in the
summertime from the concession stand and
they were kept in a fridge so they were
cool
but if you like KitKat but you gotta
like peanut butter too but is that like
your Jammy Jam no no I'm saying for me a
Kit Kat just a cool KitKat in the in the
summertime yeah
yeah I don't need any peanut butter
peanut butter is a warm thing to me
yeah to me the the and look I'm not
advocating for this because this I'm
just talking about impulse advice
straight up so reflecting on that that
being said the Reese's Sticks to me is
the best candy bar I ever created like
kind of by far too like a distant maybe
second is like a Butterfinger scenario
or like I'll have to look into it yeah
it's called Reese's Sticks Reese's
Sticks I know I've bought some impulsive
things before and just been like
dude I'm not smart I can't think of any
though I'm gonna have to think about
this one actually I did have an Impulse
buy but it was it turned out what was it
a red Cam the red V Raptor first half no
the new one yeah the the white one that
had the viewer after oh he's right when
he came so when you buy a red camera
they're good cameras obviously so
they're expensive they're expensive yes
they're way more expensive if you don't
know anything about this if you told
them how much it costs people be like
what in God's name are you talking about
yeah this isn't like oh like 1700 bucks
no this is a totally different scenario
yeah they yeah so yeah yeah they cost
more than your average car how much is
it I mean just to save people having to
Google and look this up how much is a
red camera Raptor or whatever you're
doing Raptor just for the body which
it's 20 29 or
24.99 24 999 24 999 25 000 or just the
body though no batteries no batteries no
lens no viewfinder no monitor nothing
just the body so you can't even use it
yeah you got to buy lenses and it only
fits Cinema lenses with a full frame
like it's a whole thing and those tend
to be a lot this is 100 Grand scenario
for the kit now for the V Raptor and
they're way less expensive than they
were at the camera before that but it
now they're they're cheaper because they
push them out I think more efficiently
or whatever but all in it was like
probably for that kit that I have to
that particular one is probably like 40.
almost 40 like 36 38 and that was an
Impulse buy that was an Impulse buy and
this is why I know so
I won't go through
too deep but when you buy red cameras
you're part of like a club yeah
yeah for like a better term so
um when I got the first one way back in
the day the red one for people who know
cameras are gonna remember the red one
it's literally it weighs like 20 pounds
it's like a cast iron was that was that
with the podcast
I did the good video remember good yeah
that was like episode like five I did
that with the red one so that was the
first one you bought first one I bought
the only reason and that was 25 grand
for the body too this was back in the
day here's the thing I didn't get it for
25 Grand the reason I got it they were
getting rid of them they're
discontinuing it
this is the least practical camera
probably I've ever even touched with my
bearings so it's cast iron like suit
like there's no it's it's really hard to
use but it's red you know and they're
they're getting rid of them and they're
offering
um certain people on their list or
whatever list I was on
um the opportunity to buy um no it was
part of like some form and so you could
buy for four grand because they're
getting rid of big yeah so I like I
didn't know how to use it never used it
before I was just like I know it's a
deal so I got it and I just freaking
spent the next like three months saving
up money to get the accessories to be
able to use it finally be able to use it
for however many years and then they
offered to trade it for the new like
helium 8K you know you heard a 4K this
is like 8K whatever trade it in you can
get a big discount on this thing I was
like Frick but it's only to a certain
amount of people
so that technically was an Impulse buy
two
so anyway this is how red does it they
know how to capitalize
yeah essentially right in a nutshell if
you're ready because they're like hey
this is only gonna be an offer right now
yeah they capitalize we don't have that
many that's the thing it's new we don't
have that many so they contact once
you're in the red ecosystem
working yep they get your emotions
working yep they get your animalistic
competitiveness working competitiveness
is if we didn't talk about that yeah
like you'll do some dumb [__] just from
being competitive yep oh yeah and that's
kind of that was exactly right where I
had the red helium and they were like
hey you're on our list you know we're
coming out with this thing called The V
Raptor and I heard about it already and
all these like all this Tech it was like
man now if you have that one that's it
because no one else has it only the
people so it was like me
there were I don't know how many people
were on the list but like Jason you know
Jason Momoa yeah like he was on the list
like so I felt like damn dude if you got
the white one you were one you're one of
the first people to come I think they
made I don't know do you have a serial
number on it do they number them yeah
well you know when you insure it you
have this is a real number whatever but
when you know that going in they're like
hey you don't have to buy it you can if
we if we choose to continue making these
you can you can wait till then oh yeah
for sure
but here thankfully you know like when I
got it it was all that you know everyone
was expecting it to be and you know we
we put it together and it was it's legit
it's worth it the reason that I
shouldn't have done it though is because
I bought the What's called the monstro
that's the that's the really expensive
one at the time I bought that like
literally two months before
so I got three RED cameras like
literally right now I have three of that
original helium 8K
got the monster and then the V Raptor
okay full-fledged production not bad to
record a podcast no no it's very
unrealistic no I know they're freaking
crazy yeah but that was impossible if
you're wondering we actually this is not
recorded on the red camera because it
would be just like crazy amount of data
oh yeah you would have over a terabyte
of stuff just for the podcast
all right so watch your impulsiveness
it'll make you do dumb things uh we do
the dumb things just some technical ones
here time pressure there's another thing
they threw in the mix on you like like
hey oh there's only a certain amount of
time so we do dumb things because we
don't have the time
so you have to pay attention you have to
stay ahead of the power curve you have
to not put yourself in the situations
where you're gonna do dumb [__] because
you didn't have time to do it the right
way
uh there's a couple here that are are
sort of well I guess these two kind of
connect as I was thinking through them
people do dumb [__] because they lack
experience or they lack information
they're both
a little bit harder to to control
yourself
because it's the classic you don't know
what you don't know yeah yeah it's a
it's so you actually really truly don't
know the all the best you can do to to
to cover the bases and mitigate these is
to know that you don't know to know that
there's things that you don't know to
not be like oh I got this oh you know
well I can figure this out you know to
to put yourself in that situation you
should be more humble I think humility
is what helps you with these two you
know when you don't have the experience
it's like the the person that shows up
for the Jiu Jitsu that like is a street
fighter yeah and they're like bro I can
I like they look at some skinny freaking
150 pound dude and they're like bro I'm
gonna beat this guy's ass yeah and they
just literally don't have the experience
and they don't have the information
so you this the the solution for that to
me is humility
it's actually saying hey
I'm I'm not so sure about this you
should never look at anything and think
yeah it looks pretty easy yeah and not
you should think like well there's
something some things I don't see there
um
there's some there's some information
that I don't have yeah that's what that
should be your go-to default mode is Mom
not 100 sure and I'm gonna keep my eyes
open as I try and figure this out yeah
otherwise you might do some dumb [__]
you know about Plumbing yes I do so I
was talking to Kingdom about this very
thing today
so I don't know anything why the hell
were you talking about freaking Plumbing
with yeah it's a thing why don't you
talk about Jiu Jitsu uh we do talk about
Jesus
so I had an issue with uh a toilet in my
household okay and uh it was you know it
was like a thing where something had
worn out or whatever and so I'm like a
proper valve something it was like the
little the thing that connected the the
I want to say the flush valve okay you
see I know all these terms now because I
let you into it but this is a classic
case of me not knowing what I don't know
so I go in I'm like you know what I'm
gonna look it up on YouTube like I saw
many of my problems in my life and you
know figure it out so I look it up on
YouTube and it's like boom they just you
got the diagram you got a guy do this or
whatever and I'm like cool
um I even looked it up just on on the
internet like a diagram so I'm like cool
I understand how this whole thing works
now right so I go in and of course it
doesn't like work out the things just as
broken As It Ever Was I don't know what
material so I'm like all right let me
just study this whole thing so I go back
to YouTube keep watching it so I found
this channel I wish I could tell you
which one what which one it was but it
was one of these like kind of bigger
channels like a it could have been like
a Home Depot Channel or something I
don't know if it was or not I forget
but so the guy goes into it and it's
this long ass video and I'm about to
skip it because I need to solve it right
now it's insane but I'm like no let me
just commit some time so I commit the
time and he starts talking about all
these issues that can arise when you're
just trying to fix this one issue so he
talks about like his experience with
certain times where you have to fix this
issue so this one time I'm still having
this problem so I had to go back over
here because sometimes these are made
like this and he's doing all this he's
basically giving me like his personal
experience on this thing and for every
additional thing that he would say he
demonstrated to me how much I don't know
and how much it's not just like hey
you're gonna go in and he's gonna tell
me how to do it
I ended up fixing it it's a longer story
and it doesn't matter
but that was me not knowing what I don't
know yeah so I wasn't about to take
apart my whole toilet because that was
one of the luckily you were humble
enough to recognize that there could be
some [__] going sideways yeah literally
before I made it exactly right like
before I made like a big commitment to
you know because one of the options that
I came across in my haste was take out
the whole toilet and just replace the
whole toilet but obviously I didn't have
to do that but we're not looking to do
that yeah not knowing what you don't
know can't cause you to do that kind of
dumb stuff yeah where it's like oh well
that oh that's the option because that's
the first advice I got or whatever
because in my mind that's the only
advice that I've ever heard so we do it
yep the humility will help you with your
lack of experience and your lack of
information in life
and it's just really good to remember
because you don't know what you don't
know and so you think you know and you
don't
uh and right in there too is another one
similar is lack of self-awareness
right you're just not self-aware
so you're doing dumb [__] because you're
because you're not self-aware you think
people can't see the dumb things that
you're doing you think you're out
maneuvering people all those things stem
from the fact that you just you're not
self-aware
so how do we get gain self-awareness
number one if you think you're super
self-aware you're probably not
you're probably not so take a step back
detach that's what we have to do there I
had to throw this one in there because
it does happen
uh physical and mental fatigue right
sleep deprivation like all those when
you get tired you can do some dumb [__]
that that's what can happen
and people make bad decisions when
they're physically tired people make bad
decisions when they're mentally tired
and they just break down yeah have you
ever watched True Detective
yes but not very much okay uh there's
this part in True Detective it's really
good for I didn't I did the the second
one got a bunch of bad reviews so I
didn't watch it but the first one's
freaking great
uh
uh who Woody no
um yes Matthew McConaughey plays this uh
badass character
and he's talking about he's looking he's
a he's a detective he's talking to
talking to some other detectives that
are investigating him and he's talking
about how he's looking at dead bodies
like photographs of dead bodies over and
over and over and again he's seen all
these dead bodies over his time in the
in the police force
and he says he's it's great you got to
watch it but he's talking about how when
you look at these pictures these dead
people you can see that just before they
died
they saw for a moment how easy it would
be if they just let it go
like at that moment of death they go you
know what
it's over
and and he goes on this big thing about
they realize that all the love and all
the hate and all the things were a dream
that you had inside a lock box he goes
through this thing but that's an extreme
example
of what happens when people just break
they just break from fatigue right they
just break they just can't take it
anymore and they just go you know what
I'm done yeah that's one thing that's
that's like the ultimate bad decision
that you make is like oh I just give up
but there's all kinds of bad decisions
that you can make based on the fact that
you're tired but sometimes it's not
mentally breaking sometimes you're just
not thinking straight yeah I don't know
if you've ever been around people that
are they're legitimately they're so
tired they're not thinking straight you
know you get people that have been
seriously sleep deprived they might be
they might be doing some dumb [__] so I
had to throw that one in there
physically and mental physical and
mental fatigue can definitely make
people make bad decisions and now we're
going to open up a big can
something you and I have talked about on
the Underground podcast quite a bit
which is cognitive biases
and people have a bunch of different
cognitive biases and they will make you
do dumb [__]
so confirmation bias
you know when you when you
when you have a belief you're looking to
confirm that belief and you will you
will absorb the information that's going
to support your decision and you're
gonna do some dumb [__] because you just
are listening to the people that are
telling you that it's smart
you know you can find oh for instance
like let's say you like let's say you
don't like
to run
you can go find a bunch of Articles
right now that'll be like oh you can get
you can actually find running is bad for
you yeah you can find enough articles
that'll confirm that you're right
running is bad for you yeah uh lifting
heavy yeah you know I like to lift heavy
cool you can go find a bunch of Articles
injury prone and [__] blah blah blah
blah stiffness you can find it so you
will make bad decisions based on the
fact that you are you have confirmation
bias
availability bias a similar one
this is like you act based on
the most recent information or the most
available information this is why you
know when you Google something you're
like oh what's the best
knife to buy
there's people that are paying to make
the most available click the one that
comes up first
if somebody paid for that and so
therefore it looks like this is the best
knife came up there it is Boom
um anchoring bias
this is when you when you get addicted
or you rely on the first piece of
information that you have that's what
first impressions are so important First
Impressions very important this is so
this is something I used to see in the
sale teams which was whatever the first
way someone learned to do something yes
is the way they thought was correct yeah
and it was really hard to change
people's minds
around a new procedure if they had
learned in their first platoon this is
how you do it
so you gotta you've got to be careful
that that piece of information that you
got first and the same thing this is
like I think we talked about this when
we talked about
negotiation right
um the you can use anchoring to offset
somebody yeah you know I can use it to
mess you up I can give you a low ball
offer that you're now anchored to and
you're like geez Jocko offered me seven
dollars for this knife I thought it was
worth 700. I'm like I'll give you seven
bucks for it and all of a sudden when I
offer you 50 you're like I'll take it
yeah
so be careful that hindsight bias
the tendency to believe
that an event was more predictable or
obvious than it actually was after it
occurred
I knew he was going to win that fight
right yeah
I'll tell you what I think I'm pretty
good at
when it comes to MMA right it's almost
like all bets are off like I it's almost
like I just look at it like I just don't
think I can predict what's going to
happen there's and this is for a reason
there's been fights that have happened
where I was like this is 100 this is a
done deal yeah although I did it the
other night did you watch the fights the
other night yes yeah
um watching Valentina
get beat like I
the announcer John anik
said like as what was the other girl's
name
I don't know yeah like she came out of
nowhere props to her
she's a badass
the John enik says oh and she's got much
improved Jujitsu and I'm like bro that's
what you're bragging about
that she has and she ends up with a rear
naked choke victory over bullet
Valentina amazing
I don't fall into this trap though but I
did that night I did I was like dude
this is a good luck against you got
improving Jiu Jitsu and that's your and
then you gotta really naked joke but
I immediately was like dude I'm an idiot
I'm not saying anything else I've I've
if I would have been there's been a
couple times in my life where I did bet
actual money um
on fights and I was wrong and things
that I was like this is a done deal this
is a done deal and just been wrong but
I'm certainly not a person that gets
done and says yeah I knew that was gonna
happen oh yeah
so be careful that hindsight buys
framing bias
this is the way information is presented
or framed
so
if someone like if a doctor says this
has a 90 success rate
that sounds better to them than saying
hey if I do surgery on your arm it's 90
going to heal you'd be like okay cool if
I say hey if I do surgery on your arm 10
chance it doesn't work anymore
you're like wait a second we're talking
about I should just stay tell you 90
that's the way it's framed to you that
can mess up hardly that makes you do
dumb [__] well yeah so you ever watch
Teen Wolf remember back in the day Teen
Wolf I never got into that was that a TV
show or was it a movie movie then they
did a TV show later but I'm talking
about the movie The Original this is
hell yeah
so he had a basketball coach named Bobby
finnstock one of your one of the best
characters ever created in my opinion
but super like just checked out coach
just so used to his tradition of losing
he's like you know anyway he had a
famous like
pre-game speech so they're like hey
coach you got any inspiring words or
whatever he said he's like uh yeah um
hey you guys have nothing to be ashamed
of go out there and do your best that's
what he said
so it's like of course you know like the
facts are nothing to be ashamed of do
you bet like that's all factually true
but what he how he framed it was like
you guys already or we all have like
things on our mind that we're ashamed of
you know about this team which you know
they were losing teams or whatever but
how he framed it was like he has already
lost you know you don't be you got
nothing to be ashamed of kind of a thing
that's not framing bias does in Teen
Wolf does the guy turn into a wolf on
the basketball court yeah yeah and they
like let him play
he's all good at it yeah he mutates or
whatever yeah yeah then he's all good he
can he can dunk and stuff and then he
turns Super popular in school girls are
attracted to him for something you know
he literally got hit he's like Harry
yeah he's half wolf werewolf whatever
Jack
um it's a fun movie though
some things that'll make you do dumb
[__] bias wise over confidence bias
clear what that is there's also under
confidence bias right like you don't
think you can do it well
you're probably not going to make a good
decision you know if you've got an
opportunity to do something like I could
never do that cool then you don't do it
and now you don't get the win or
overconfidence I could do this no
problem make your decision and you end
up looking like a jackass yeah
so be careful that sunk cost fallacy
these are all kind of ones that we know
about
um gamblers fallacy
the event the the belief that past
events influence the likelihood of
future events even when the two events
are unrelated
for example believing that a coin toss
is more likely to land on heads if it is
landed on tail several times in a row
that'll get you it's still a 50 50
chance man oddly enough it's still just
a 50 50 chance that's a weirdo it
doesn't seem like it is what it is
that's one of those I mean most
cognitive biases fall into this but
you kind of gotta train yourself in a
way and like you have to be super aware
because that one in particular just like
how you mentioned it doesn't feel like
it and that one's really hard to like
believe at first especially when you're
like because there's ways to look at it
yeah yeah yeah because so if you're like
if you're like hey I have this coin and
I'm gonna flip it 10 times in a row it's
gonna land on heads
that's a different set of odds right
there than you actually flipping it and
then it happens to go in heads nine
times in a row and then the likelihood
of it landing on heads again
is is still 50 50. but before you flip
any of the coins ever and you say I'm
gonna flip it 10 times in a row then you
got a different set of odds and it's
crazy so I'm saying so some people and
I'm one of these people because I
thought I had roulette figured out like
I was about to bring up
where I thought that I was like because
I was thinking of it like before any
roles have done so I was like hey if I
get you know if I I'm gonna bed on red
or black or whatever and I'm just keep
betting on that rent because the I the
the chances of it landing on red like
however many times rows becomes smaller
and smaller smaller exponentially so I'm
guaranteed to win at least my money back
so it's like a foolproof system you
figured it out yeah that's what I
figured and um my sort of hits green
you're like well after every rule the
odds go back to what they were in the
beginning so technically it doesn't
technically yes that's true but as you
start rolling it's it's different did
you do the thing where you like double
your money that you're betting and you
see what I'm saying yeah I never did it
yeah it never played I mean it
yeah I never did my system so basically
you can do like oh I bet a dollar on
black right if I lose I put two dollars
on black yeah if I lose again I put four
dollars on black right if I lose again
I'll put eight dollars on yeah that was
the system yeah essentially
it's not I never tried it down and
what's weird what makes it not work out
is not only that it resets but there's
also that the two odds the two greens on
there yeah
bro it's not yeah it'll catch you
um let's see halo effect this is like
when you judge people's overall
characteristics based on one
characteristic like that'll make you
make bad decisions oh yeah
um allusion of control this is our we we
think we have more ability to control
things than we actually do
that's gonna make you do some dumb [__]
uh
negativity bias and optimism bias these
two are you know just what they sound
right if you have a negative attitude
well if you you will lean in that
direction you might make bad decisions
because of it
um so there you go there's a bunch of
biases cognitive biases that you can
that that pay into us making bad
decisions and look there's a bunch of
these the last one I will say to cover
today
and this is one that I think Echo
Charles this has had the biggest impact
on your life since you and I started
hanging out and discussing all these
topics and that is short-term thinking
versus long-term thinking strategic
thinking versus tactical thinking
any time you consider what the long-term
outcome is going to be you will make a
smarter decision than if you just focus
on what I'm gonna feel like or how I'm
going to be gratified in the next seven
minutes
that will lead you to doing dumb [__] so
think
strategic think about the long term with
all decisions that you make and you will
do a better job making better decisions
so
there you go these are this is my list
uh some examples of some of the many
many things that there are
that drive us to make bad decisions that
drive us to do dumb [__]
and I also think you need to think about
this what kind of person are you
you have to know what kind of person you
are you have to know what kind of person
you are you have to know what Tendencies
you have because you have Tendencies I
have tendencies
and if you start applying these various
subjects these various examples these
various factors that can make you make
bad decisions you're gonna know that
there's some of these things you're more
susceptible to
maybe you're more susceptible to your
animalistic Behavior maybe you're more
susceptible to Your Ego getting out of
control maybe you're more susceptible to
some of these cognitive biases that
we're talking about
but knowing who you are
so you can watch out and you can lean in
the other direction to make sure you
make better decision is also an
important part of making good decisions
so know what kind of person you are and
don't let
don't let your Tendencies get the best
of you so the way that you can kind of
make that happen is by detaching and one
of the easiest ways to detach is to take
a step back and write things down I'm
just saying when you write things down
you are detached from them you can see
other perspectives ask yourself what
would if I was if I was someone else
right now and I was looking at me and I
was about to do this thing
what would I tell myself
no I can afford this vehicle it's a car
I've always wanted it's my dream car
well your payments are going to be 1700
bucks a month
I know but this is going to be it's
going to make me really feel good about
myself and also clients are going to see
me in this car and they'll know that I'm
a player like yeah but you only make
four grand a month
I know but I'm that's gonna grow it's
like
what would you be telling yourself if
you were talking to you
you'd probably be saying hey man let's
go let's go look at the Chevys
and write down also write down what the
long-term outcome is going to be
versus what the short term
gratification you're going to get
and that will help you to do the right
things and to make good decisions
very powerful seems small
yeah it seems almost too simple right oh
that's the solution to improve my life
probably like 75 to 85 yeah yeah no it's
a big number in any given any given
Endeavor yeah but most of all in the big
game yeah in the big game in the Life
game if you cannot do dumb [__] be way
better off yeah seems so easy
how about this I would even say this
this is how powerful every one of these
is if you just took I don't know let's
say the first one and the last one we'll
say first one alcohol so Carrie carry K
dog you know we all know him love them
he the way he because he doesn't drink
he quit drinking so he
he put it in a way where I was like
that's a really impactful way to put it
even though it's we knew the idea but he
put it this is what he said he said well
you know after a while like you know you
you get in trouble when he's talking
about himself he's like you get I get in
trouble when I drink and I get myself in
trouble when I drink versus oh I don't
drink and every single aspect of my life
just gets better and better and better
and doesn't stop yeah it's it's a more
logical decision not to drink because I
think I was asking I was like that's
cool you don't drink so I was like what
you don't drink at all at all I was like
why are you like you think you'll just
relapse and go make cause trouble he was
like no it's not necessarily that and
then he said that's what he said where
it's like my life gets better
um it keeps getting better and better
and better and better and does not stop
that's what he said
little decisions it's true stack them up
so you stack that onto what the last one
was
um the short game versus long game like
think about that whereas like that's on
your radar with every kind of move
you're making it throughout your day oh
man no drinking clear oh man you'd be
doing some good stuff no drinking
thinking long term
it's gonna move you in the right
direction oh yeah awesome uh hopefully
this helps people out
and uh with that let's we've got to make
a decision on what we're uh putting in
our bodies right fuel wise I had a Mulk
right when we got done training today so
good very nice earned bro I'm telling
you that yeah did you did you do all
rounds today did you take any no I just
I took one round off and then towards
the end you know when everyone was kind
of done there was today there was no
really like Hey we're all done that's
what I feel it kind of faded so I took
one around on off aside from you know
Sloan and them and kept going a couple
times yeah yeah yeah and I took one
right now yeah it's um it's a good time
I felt that I earned my milk the the the
idea of No Easy rounds yeah you think
like oh yeah sure there did you just do
your rest between rounds or whatever so
it's like
to say it doesn't sound as impactful as
it actually feels because when you have
like let's face it you're only in the
mixed class or whatever and this is not
good bad this is the nature of rolling
it's actually good what you're about to
say yeah like that's a good type of
training yeah in the class you wrote you
beat this guy up you get a little bit
swept you got someone that's even you're
getting a bunch of different looks yep a
bunch of different looks and varying
levels of output
but
it's like if you even want to do
Jiu-Jitsu in the environment like this
where everybody's black belt in in kind
of better black belts your output has to
be kind of at the top the whole time
otherwise you're kind of not even doing
Jiu Jitsu you're just being a dummy
for the guy yeah because everyone's so
good
so you go through however you usually do
like 10 Rounds that's right usually yeah
so let's say you do even you do the
eight or nine rounds of that
bro it's like it's way different than
doing 10 rounds in the mixed glass you
need fuel you need that fuel did you
ever go on your way there I had to go on
the way there I'll tell you what I was I
didn't want to train like like if it
wasn't for the commitment yeah because
I'm not you know obviously I'm showing
up but plus you kind of pressured me
into it yeah
but uh I man I had that I had that go on
the way you know just walked out of my
house grabbed a go drink it on the way
down here and finished it in the locker
room and by the time like I got out on
the mat I was warm I was like yep I can
feel it yeah I'm ready to go well
Attitude Change yeah my attitude changed
last time when I came and trained with
you guys in this um sesh I didn't really
feel like training but this time I did I
didn't feel like training because like I
said I got reminded of it it was on the
radar I had I wasn't rushing doing other
stuff I was like bro I'm completely
ready you need you need time like
mentally to prepare yeah and I feel like
you know actually no here's when I need
mental time to prepare when it's just me
and you
know it's true but like this kind it I
don't you know because like
you I always feel like I have like
something proof because like if you like
really beat me up I don't feel good like
I feel like oh you're just gonna like
hold it over me and then if I do good
I'm kind of like I don't have to say
nothing but I can be like yeah what up
or whatever kind of a thing I feel like
there's a little bit more at stake or
writing we'll see but this guy I don't
feel that for whatever reason I feel
like it's like so everyone's so cool too
yeah so my mind was kind of
put it this way I want my thoughts and
my what I was doing throughout the day
weren't in they weren't interrupted by
okay now I gotta go train you know I'm
like Frick I was just thinking I'm still
thinking about this a little bit now I
gotta go train or whatever with these
hard guys I'm like Frick my mind knows
it wasn't even there but today today I
had time good today my mind was there
nonetheless a lot of output and yes I
had to go on the way down yeah all good
it's a go
do it then monk then mock that's a good
procedure for life you gotta you gotta
try the super cold milk bro I'm telling
you okay you'd be happy well my wife
makes this banana milk in the morning
with the banana milk yeah uh the powder
man she does a good
now she makes me like a little extra
little hater because normally I don't I
don't like to eat that much in the
morning yeah I don't I'm talking this
after I'm talking this is like nine
o'clock you know oh after the workout
after the workout you know kind of
she'll kind of like bring a little malt
to me and she got hers in like a Shaker
yeah
you're sophisticated good right it
tastes so good uh so yeah get yourself
some go get yourself some Mulk
and you can get the stuff at
jocklefuel.com
that's uh where it's at man Taco
fuel.com you can also get it at Vitamin
Shop you can get it at the military
commissaries I got a bunch of my friends
hit me up from military comment they
send me pictures
uh Hanford Dash doors HEB Meyer
Wakefern ShopRite while we're stealing
Wawa go grab some in Wawa there's
there's hostilities man in these
convenience stores there's hostilities
FYI there's big companies
and I mean the biggest of companies the
biggest of Beverage companies they go in
to these convenience stores and they buy
those slots they buy the Shelf space you
know why they do that
because they're threatened
it's a threat we are a threat yeah and
we are like
we are like the rebels in the Star Wars
right the empires are look the empires
if you're flying around They Don't
Really Care once you threatened them
they gotta come they gotta fight yeah
and that's what they're doing
so go into these convenience stores
clear the shelves let them know what's
up it's us against the empires the
empires by the way are trying to poison
you we all know this yeah they're doing
evil things that's the crazy part about
it and you mentioned this on some I
don't know one of your Instagram things
where you know they'll call you can call
it like these industry standard like
kind of
you know oh yeah it's just general
advertisement or whatever and you called
it brainwashing and I'm like oh Draco
being dramatic but then I thought I was
like wait a second that's exactly what
it is and you know they use all actually
some of this stuff where it's like you
know framing bias like all this where
yeah they'll just they'll say the good
like parts of it there can be like three
good parts of something short term by
the way three and then there's like 12
bad parts of it short and long term 12.
they won't say any of the 12th and
they'll do it and then they're like here
you go here's your little product drink
as much of it as you want in fact let me
put something in there to make you wanna
drink as much of it as we want you to
right knowing it's bad for you knowing
if you drink the more and more and more
of this stuff you drink the worse and
worse and worse Health you will have
literally not that's not a metaphor
that's like literally the deal so also I
learned this thing and I don't I I don't
want to speak too much into it but I
heard this thing it's a girl on a
podcast and she was like America so here
bear with me this is just what I heard
America has this thing called single
dose toxicity or something like this
where and look into this so but keep
this in your on your mind where America
is a thing as far as regulations go
single dose toxicity meaning like if
it's harmless in one dose it's fine it's
admissible to be in your product
but you take 10 doses the toxicity goes
10 times it's no longer single dose
technically but that's not the rule the
rule isn't 10 doses the rule is single
dose toxicity so you get a energy drink
single dose toxicity you get a you know
maybe you have some chips or maybe you
drink a soda for your for your thing or
maybe you're eating something that's not
like all natural whatever which let's
face it you know it's it's hard to
navigate that sometimes now you got your
toxicity up five times ten times and
these guys are just pushing it on you
the more the better and then to the
point they're saying oh this Jocko go
all natural no toxicity all this stuff
oh my god of course they're gonna buy
that let's let's fight against that
that's literally the bad guy no the
rebels doing the good stuff
uh so there you go go get some go get
some Jocko fuel go get some
originusa.com speaking of Jiu Jitsu you
should betraying Jitsu if you're not
training Jitsu you're just missing out
you miss it you're missing out I've had
hundreds and hundreds if not thousands
of people say I wish I would have
started earlier yeah
so go train jiu jitsu you're going to
train Jiu Jitsu originusa.com get a ghee
get a rash guard All American made by
the way
it's all 100 American made
we got jeans you could do Jiu Jitsu in
the jeans by the way if you wanted to
because you can squat in the jeans like
this is just the facts
so we make everything in America we got
the hunt line the hunt lines out I was I
was up in Montana people were asking me
about the hotline yup the hotline's live
man
you can order your hunt gear
so go check that out
that's what we got going on it's at
originusa.com also represented on this
path
Jocko store go to joostore.com so we can
get your uh good good shirts shirts is
good
I think I'll make a few more other
variations of that one okay because I
wanted his legs that was a good one to
represent I'll tell you fired a guy I
was at the I was at the Expo West which
is the Natural Foods event and I went up
there we were showing people Jocko feels
first of all it's crazy how many people
know me and like I didn't know you had
supplements I didn't know you had a
drink I didn't know you had ready to
drink protein like people didn't know
that I mean a lot of them did but a lot
of them didn't a pretty big number but a
dude came up and just started saying the
good video like word for word and I was
like Jack in the game oh yeah but what's
crazy is he didn't know he had he said
the whole video like memorize we were
laughing and he said well I didn't know
he had supplements like yeah we got him
man I'm sorry I'm doing a bad job
putting out the word yeah but there you
go oh good this path all kinds of good
stuff also discipline equals Freedom too
you want to represent that represent we
also have the shirt Locker so don't
forget about that if you're not on it
it's okay it's cool just check it check
it out as much as you want I got a
little um what do you call it like a
call it a sneak peek kind of see what
you're dealing with for yourself
yeah yeah so it's like it's not a
surprise but it's not a full reveal but
anyway subscription scenario get a new
shirt every month it's a cool one you're
still representing on the path just in a
more a little bit more creative more in
the game kind of way people like it
underground.com that's our that's our
own platform that we can't get kicked
off of because we own it
so they can't kick us off Jocko
underground.com check out our YouTube
page check out originusa YouTube page
check out the Jocko field YouTube page
we got people putting out content
info for you on those psychological
warfare check out flipsidecanvas.com
obviously I've written a bunch of books
final spin leadership strategy and
tactics Field Manual the code evaluation
program a bunch of books disciplinary
freedom field manual the way the warrior
Kid series by the way the best kids
books ever written
yeah did I say that yes I did I've never
read a kid's book that was better than
the way the warrior Kid book series have
you Echo no anyone has a book that's
better than the way of the warrior kids
series please let me know and I will
talk about it on here I'll cover it on
the podcast
if not then get these books for every
kid that you know and help them have a
better life Mikey and the dragons about
faced by hackworth extreme ownership
dichotomy leadership Ashland front we
have a leadership consultancy go to
echelonfront.com if you want to help
with your leadership inside your
organization we have a bunch of live
events that we do as well don't forget
we have the online training academy for
how to lead yourself in life
extreme ownership.com I'm on there
answering questions we have a bunch of
content that you can go through a bunch
of courses you can take you can learn
how to deal with problems with
leadership you can learn how to live
better extreme ownership.com go check
that out and also if you want to help
service members active and retired you
want to help their families you want to
help gold star families check out
Markley's mom mama Lee she's got a
charity organization and if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
Americas Mighty Warriors dot org and
don't forget about Micah Fink and what
he's got going on with Heroes and
horses.org current report from the field
Micah Fink has just saw down a bunch of
trees he's built a raft and he is
forging a river
with a horse at this time
chasing a bear with a spear crazy so
give it up for Micah Fink and what he's
doing to help you help out our veterans
if you want to connect with us echo's
Attica Charles I'm at Jocko willing
watch out for the algorithm it's it's
strong it's there it's a beast It's Got
Claws it's got teeth it'll put its teeth
around your neck and kill you the
algorithm so watch out
thanks to all of our military personnel
around the world who are out there
making the best decisions
for us
to protect us and protect our way of
life here and also thanks to police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service and all First
Responders thank you you all for making
the right decisions to keep us safe
here at home
and everyone else out there life is a
series of decisions
every day
little decisions big decisions
decision after decision but all those
decisions
have consequences
they can have good consequences
they can have bad consequences but they
have consequences
they put you on the path
in life
so make good decisions
and don't do dumb [__]
and until next time the zeko and Jocko
out